this video is brought to you by policy genius who
you have family members who depend on your income
you need life insurance and that's where
policy genius comes in more on them in a bit
an ancient evil a scourge a curse embroiled
in a bitter feud against humanity since the
dawn of time from the cradle of the first
sapiens it walked with us among us inside us
whenever our first villages towns and cities
sprung whenever our civilization expanded
the enemy was there silent and undetected ready
for the cull it could happen at any time it
started with a cough that wouldn't go away then
the first droplets of blood and sputum stained the
palm of your hand and then your pale body
started to waste away as if it was being
consumed from the inside our forefathers used to
call it the wasting disease thysis consumption
white plague today we know it as tuberculosis
the deadliest disease to ever crawl the earth
the main responsible pathogen of tuberculosis
or tb is the mycobacterium tuberculosis this
microorganism has accompanied humans throughout
every stage of our history during which time it
may have killed more people than any other living
being before we get into the history of this
disease let's quickly profile it the bacterium
tuberculosis usually attacks the lungs of the
host but it can affect also the spine brain
and other organs the infection does not always
result in manifest illness therefore there are two
tb-related conditions latent tb infection and tb
disease people with latent infection do not have
any symptoms they appear generally healthy and
are not contagious they can however test positive
for the disease and in later stages can develop a
full-on infection if their immune system is
weakened it may take up to 40 years before the
mycobacterium reactivates and starts attacking its
host from the inside on the other hand patients
who live in an environment in which tb is highly
prevalent or who have a weak immune system may
develop active tb disease and fall ill from the
start in most cases they will experience a bad
cough lasting three weeks or longer they will
develop acute chest pain and eventually they may
cough up blood other visible signs include fatigue
weight loss fever night sweats and a sickly pala
these patients will spread them tuberculosis
in the air as they cough or even speak thus
infecting those near them family members friends
schoolmates and co-workers are all particularly
at risk when a healthy host breathes in the tb
bacteria these will settle inside the lungs in
most cases once in the lungs the bacterial will
lead to necrosis of the healthy tissue causing
the formation of cavities and hard nodules the
tubercules that lend their name to the disease
as they attack the pulmonary tissue the bacteria
can erode blood vessels which causes the person to
cough up bright red blood and if the infection
enters the bloodstream the mycobacteria can
spread throughout the body causing miliary
tuberculosis tuberculosis meningitis or other
variants of the disease such as potts disease
which causes spinal deformity in all cases the
ruthless basili of the mycobacterium genus will
set to work causing a process called caseiation
from the latin word for cheese what happens
is the invaders will destroy healthy tissue
leaving in their place a thick cheesy substance
if the progressive erosion reaches a major artery
the patients may die of internal hemorrhage
otherwise they may experience a longer more
painful death as their organs fail one after
the other from the outside patients will appear
as if consumed from the inside slowly wasting
away to an unseen vampire inside their own body
the genus mycobacterium may have originated
more than 150 million years ago later evolving
into an ancestor of m tuberculosis this was
present in east africa as early as three
million years ago when it may have infected early
hominids in fact the skull of a 000 year old homo
erectus was found to present lesions compatible
with tuberculosis meningitis much later about
15 to 35 000 years ago another strain appeared
which gave origins the modern m tuberculosis
and its related variants including m bovis
responsible for bovine tb then from east africa
early human hosts migrated to neighboring lands
and then throughout the world carrying the scourge
buried deep inside their lungs the next forensic
evidence of death by tb was found on the skeletons
of a young woman and a child they were found in
the submerged village of atletian israel destroyed
by a tsunami some 9 000 years ago in 2008 a team
from university college london confirmed that the
unhappy family had died of tuberculosis adlet
yam is considered one of the oldest known human
settlements and one of the earliest to present
evidence of cattle farming this detail seemed
to confirm an early theory that human tb may have
originated from bovine tb humans can get infected
from cows that are infected with their disease and
that is why we pasteurize milk but m tuberculosis
and m bovis are two separate bacterial strains
which originated independently albeit from a
common ancestor there is an indirect link however
between the spread of human tb and the practice
of herding animals when humans evolved from
hunter-gatherers to farmers they started living
in larger communities with increased population
density and larger families living under the same
roof there were simply more chances for infection
as the earliest civilizations dawned on our planet
they unwittingly helped the cruel bacillus to grow
and the disease left its indelible mark cases of a
disease similar to tb were documented in egyptian
texts more than 5 000 years ago and some mummies
even presented skeletal deformities typical of
potts disease if there were any doubts about the
presence of tb in ancient egypt these were wiped
out by pathologist professor andreas nerlich in
1997 he identified traces of them tuberculosis
dna in tissues extracted from a mummy according to
medical historian dr dm daniel indirect references
to the prevalence of the disease in egypt can
even be found in the bible in leviticus 26 16
after moses has led the israelites away from
slavery in egypt god warns his people what could
happen should they violate his covenant i will
do this to you i will bring on you sudden terror
wasting diseases and fever that will destroy your
sight and sap your strength a similar punishment
for disobedience appears in deuteronomy 28 22 with
the same reference to a wasting disease according
to rabbinical tradition the book of leviticus was
written around some 3400 years ago this was around
the same time that tb was described in india in
a sanskrit him and sometime later in a chinese
medical text the spread of the disease was not
limited to africa and eurasia of course tb was
once believed to have reached the americas stowed
away inside the lungs of conquistadors and other
european colonizers but a 1994 research paper by
dr w.l salo at the university of minnesota found
traces of em tuberculosis and a peruvian mummy of
the 10th century a.d this proved that the disease
had been wasting away bodies in america well ahead
of columbus's landing now in a video that features
so much death and disease we really don't need to
remind you about the importance of life insurance
nobody likes to think about their own mortal
coil but the reality is that it's an important
layer of protection for many families especially
single-income households fortunately this policy
genius and their award-winning policy options
ranked number one by forbes whether you've
been putting off your purchase or you just
never really thought about it policy genius
is the team that you want to check in with
this is a third-party marketplace that works
for you not for the insurance company so you can
trust that their license experts are going to
give you solid and unbiased advice life insurance
premiums might seem like a financial drain but you
could save 1 300 or more per year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance policies if
you're interested head to policygenius.com to get
started in just a few minutes you can work out how
much coverage you need and compare personalized
quotes to find your best price when you're ready
to apply the policy genius team will handle the
paperwork and the scheduling for free you could
save 50 or more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius and getting covered now
locks in your rate over the course of a 10 or 20
year policy those savings really do add up and
best of all eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as one week so head to policygenius.com
to get started you will be glad you did because
when it comes to insurance it's nice to get
it right now let's get back to our video
by the 5th century bc tuberculosis was well known
in greece the father of medicine hippocrates
called it tysus and ranked it as the most
considerable disease he also noted that
it mainly felled young adults aged 18 to 35.
what it failed to recognize was that this was
an infectious disease and it would be centuries
before medical science reached that conclusion
the ailment later known as consumption was
believed to be a consequence of poor diet
poor living standards or simply inherited
from parents and ancestors greek physician
galen working for roman emperor marcus aurelius
in 174 a.d recommended a course of treatment for
fresh air milk and sea voyages after the fall of
the western roman empire there's little written
record of tb in europe the only exception is
the condition known as scrofulo caused when m
tuberculosis infects the lymph nodes in the neck
king clover's the first of the franks initiated
a curious practice in 496 a.d the royal
touch according to tradition frankish and
later french and british monarchs had the power
to heal skarafula with their hands you sit on a
throne of lies the tradition continued until the
reign of queen anne of great britain and ireland
in the early 18th century despite the privilege
of requiring a monarch for its treatment scraffola
did not appear to be a major concern during the
middle ages probably because it was overshadowed
by the big plague pandemics of the 6th and 14th
centuries or the recurrent famines it was only
in the mid-17th century authorities had to take
notice of the huge toll exacted by consumption by
then also known as white plague the london bills
of mortality of the time recorded that 20 percent
of all deaths in the city were due to consumption
medical schools across europe took a keen interest
in finding the causes of the disease in 1650
the university of paris expressed doubts that
isis may have a contagious nature but the
commonly accepted view was that tb was due to
a hereditary defect as it appears particularly
severe in certain families despite advances in
medical sciences and living standards the tb
epidemic continued to grow out of proportion
during the 18th century the industrial revolution
with consequent growth of cities and increased
population density may have played a part as it
had happened millennia earlier the bacillus curse
could not forgive our evolutionary leaps mortality
due to tb peaked around the 1780s its death rate
in england being 1.25 percent that's between 90
and 100 deaths per thousand more poignantly it was
estimated that one out of every four deaths
in england was attributable to the disease
this was a catastrophe worse than war famine
crime industrial accidents natural disasters or
any other disease known to mankind tuberculosis
was widespread ubiquitous sudden persistent it
was as common as life and death themselves and
yet the 19th century reacted by romanticizing it
consumption sufferers were described as live pale
melancholic souls bathed in an almost supernatural
aura coughing blood and wasting a weight and
nothing was almost considered fashionable
to the upper levels of society the poe lord byron
once remarked to a friend that he would have liked
to die of consumption because the ladies would
all say look at that poor byron how interesting
he looks in dying the fashionable aspect was fed
by the false belief that consumption affected
fine delicate precocious people who dabbled in
dissolute living in other words an interesting
way of dying for people who led interesting lives
for example consumption seemed to be particularly
prominent among artists to name a few in the 19th
century the illness claimed the geniuses of poet
john keats frederick chopin and all the bronte
sisters in the early 20th century playwright
anton chekhov painter amadeo modigliani and
france kafka all join them in palliative demise
another school of thought attributed a rather more
sinister origin to the wasting disease vampirism
in her book catching breath researcher catherine
lockheed tells the story of a new england family
the rays between 1845 and 1851 mr ray and two of
his sons died of consumption in 1854 another son
henry began to feel ill henry's extended family
and friends started to worry how could they save
him not grasping the concept of infection they
concluded that the undead rays were feeding
on henry at night the locals exhumed the father
and the two siblings discovering fresh blood
inside the heart of one of them they burned
the organ rearranged the bones of the alleged
vampire and buried him again of course henry
lived happily ever after for about two months
then his condition worsened and he died surprise
surprise it wasn't vampires something similar
happened again in new england to a young man
called edwin brown in this case edwin's friends
burns the heart of his sister mercy collected the
ashes and made a remedial potion for him to drink
no surprise there poor edwin followed mercy
and other relatives to an early grave what
is surprising about the brown case is that it
took place in 1892. ten years earlier german
physician robert cox had identified the cause
of the ancient curse mycobacterium tuberculosis
but let's proceed in order between 1803 and 1819
french doctor renee leyneck made a significant
contribution in the fight against tv back then
consumption scruffola and other conditions were
still believed to be separate ailments leneck
argued that they all shared a common cause the
presence of small lesions in the lungs lymph nodes
spine or other organs twenty years later german
doctor johan lukashonline named these legions
tubercules and the disease tuberculosis now would
have become easier for physicians to identify and
diagnose the condition thanks also to another one
of lennox contributions the stethoscope but still
they could offer little in terms of treatments
not much had changed since the times of galen
patients were prescribed healthy diets and outdoor
activities such as horseback riding even better
if the treatment was administered in one of the
dedicated sanatoria active since 1859. six years
later another french doctor jour antoine villemon
made a major breakthrough in animal experiments
he proved that the sputum of a consumptive child
could infect a rabbit tuberculosis had finally
been recognized as an infectious disease at this
stage dr [ __ ] entered the fray determined
to isolate the microbe responsible for tb
the physician used tubercules extracted from
the lungs of infected animals crushed them and
spread them on glass after some trial and error
he found the appropriate staining agents methylene
blue with the addition of potassium hydroxide
after a 24-hour exposure [ __ ] described how
quote verifying rod-like forms became
apparent in the tubercular mass for the
first time he had identified the tubercle bacillus
or mycobacterium tuberculosis as we know it today
[ __ ] published his findings in 1882 a scientific
discovery which made headlines across the world
but there was still much road to cover before a
cure could be found [ __ ] himself had extracted
from tuberculosis tissue a substance called
tuberculin which he believed could be a cure it
proved to be ineffective at treating tb but it
was very reliable at diagnosing it for several
decades surgery appeared as the only curative
option in 1896 italian surgeon carlo forliani
routinely introduced a procedure called artificial
pneumothorax or surgically induced collapsed lung
the method had been first tried by dr ramdage
in london in 1834 and he had taken inspiration
from another italian doctor who in the late 17th
century had found that a consumptive patient had
improved after a sword wound had caused his lung
to collapse clinical trials in the 1920s and 30s
showed that this procedure was efficacious in
up to 70 of tuberculosis patients of course it
was incredibly invasive and had plenty of side
effects the alternative was even worse though
thoracoplasty this surgical technique was
designed to collapse tuberculosis cavities by
the resection of ribs from the chest wall so how
about prevention a vaccine was introduced in 1921
by french bacteriologists albert calmet and camil
guerin who developed an attenuated strain of m
bovis callius which could be inoculated in
children the vaccine known as the bcg is
still used in several countries science marched
on unstoppable in 1944 ukrainian microbiologist
salman avaxman working at rutgers university new
jersey discovered an efficacious curative agent
antimicrobial streptomyosin in 1948 the who and
unicef launched a massive anti-tb campaign nearly
30 million people were treated with tuberculin and
those who resulted negative received a shot of bcg
another leap forward took place in 1952 with
the successful testing of isoniazid the first
oral microbactericidal drug the discovery was
followed by the introduction of further antibiotic
therapies in the late 1950s and early 1960s
pyrazimide thamyatol and ryphambusin are still
the backbone of current anti-tb therapy the curse
of humankind was slowly being defeated at least in
industrialized countries drugs played an important
role of course alongside better sanitation
educational campaigns and the establishment of
public health practices to give you an example
the rate of deaths from tb in england and the u.s
was about 190 per hundred thousand people in 1900
by 1960 it had dropped to six or seven in the west
tuberculosis had become an almost forgotten relic
of the past remembered as little more than
a plot device to kill off the heroine of an
italian romantic opera but in other parts of the
world the enemy remained vigilant stubborn lethal
figures from the cdc and the who indicate
that in 2018 to 2019 1.7 billion people were
infected with m tuberculosis every year about 10
million new people become ill with the disease
of them about 1.5 million will die according to
the who this makes tb the world's top infectious
killer 84 of all fatalities are aged 15 or above
and more than half of men about 13 roughly 200 000
are hiv-positive patients who are at greater risk
of contracting and dying from tb the distribution
of the disease is far from homogenous as almost 90
of cases are concentrated in 30 countries mainly
developing nations in which the spread of tb
is facilitated by poverty poor sanitation and
lack of healthcare infrastructure about half
of all tuberculosis patients are found in just
eight countries bangladesh china india indonesia
nigeria pakistan philippines and south africa and
yet i should stress that tb is now curable with
a standard six-month course of poor antibiotics
but it is a complex treatment requiring support
and supervision where these are not consistent
a patient may not fully comply with the therapy
and the disease can become drug resistant the who
identifies drug-resistant tb as a public health
threat a 2019 report estimated that close to half
a million patients have developed resistance to
standard antibiotics even if patients are being
correctly treated and supported they are at risk
of dying from an underlying comorbidity in 2014
dr chow han lin published a study reviewing the
medical history of 2016 db positive taiwanese
patients 249 of them died over the 2003-2 period
but only 17 percent succumbed to tb the rest died
of other causes such as tumors cardiovascular
disease or other bacterial infections add another
complication at the time of producing this video
health services worldwide fighting against the
covet-19 pandemic the disruption placed on health
services may reduce the diagnosis and treatment of
tb cases by 25 to 50 percent which could increase
the global death toll of tuberculosis by 400 000
casualties in 2020 alone moreover the economic
impact of the pandemic may worsen gdp per capita
and under nutrition to key risk factors which
contribute to increased incidence of the disease
wh modeling has suggested that in 2020 to 2025
period the number of tb cases could increase by
more than 1 million per year progress has been
made and is being made to rid humanity of its
most stubborn antagonist the leaders of all u.n
member states have committed to ending this global
epidemic by 2030 backed up by concrete milestones
and targets at the end of 2019 global indicators
for the reduction in disease burden in several
high prevalence countries were moving in the right
direction but at global levels progress is not on
track and the covid19 emergency is threatening to
hinder or even reverse what improvements have been
achieved but is there an end in sight catherine
lockheed who i already quoted argues that the
evolutionary paths of humanity and m tuberculosis
are intertwined closely nip together pandemics
have come and gone diseases have been eradicated
but tb has always been the constant drone
in the background for all its fashionable
aura in the 19th century tb has been and is a
disease which thrives on poverty overcrowding
and inequality which are also constant backdrops
to the story of humans on earth medical science
and zebra is progressing as of august 2021
the globaldiseasedatabaseclinicaltrials.gov
a total of 845 clinical studies looking for new
tuberculosis treatments 138 of them are in the
late phase 3 stage which looks promising for the
future but medical science may not be enough of
a solution in lockheed's words until we see
universal improvement in living conditions
access to healthcare the effects of poverty
and all the other markers of inequality then tb
is going nowhere so i hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget to
subscribe and as always thank you for watching